we we're gonna continue to have problems
of course you want problems because
without without those problems you're
not gonna continue to grow the the ideal
thing is like my problems at age 37 are
thankfully better than my problems at
age 27 yeah and which were better than
my problems at age 17 and so you and I
grew up really poor that that that
presents a particular set of financial
problems but also instability problems
with respect to our parents or our
families and drug abuse and alcohol
abuse those are just really bad problems
and then you and I had the corporate
problems throughout our 20s right yeah
we we had these problems of I'm working
too many hours I mean what what a
privilege it is to be able to work too
many hours right but it doesn't mean
that it's not a problem and even now we
we have problems like you know the
camera that we order doesn't come with
the appropriate lens cap or whatever my
dad won't talk to me
you know yeah it's just different
problems those are two different
problems for sure you want to talk about
that and then we'll talk about some
perspective stuff um let's talk about
the perspective stuff first and then I
can kind of talk about well it doesn't
matter where we start where do you want
to start you want me to start oh yeah
you can't you came to me and said hey uh
you know you and I we had a really good
podcast about parents yes it was episode
142 does that sound right Sean yeah
that's Mel right it was a great episode
I kind of you know put everything on the
table with my relationship with my dad
had a funeral for the relationship I
wished you had and it really was healing
like I felt better afterwards but I came
to you talking about how I was waking up
on a regular basis angry very very angry
at bailing yeah every single day waking
up angry at man if it wasn't just for
you know my dad's beliefs or the if it
wasn't for the organization that he
follows like him and I can have this
really good relationship and it would
make me angry because I had this in my
head like oh man if if he would just
only if you would just only do this one
thing or if he would just only see this
one point
then him and I could have this amazing
relationship and it's that podcast that
we had it was a great podcast and I feel
like I feel like it was um it was very
therapeutic and it was I'm sure that it
helps some people but the problem that I
had with that episode was I didn't I
still didn't have a clear answer
right like I had an answer that was
helping me move forward but I didn't
have a clear answer and waking up every
morning angry that is an indicator that
was an indicator for me like something
is wrong I have to every single morning
go through these perspectives and that's
where you and I started talking about
this so I would basically wake up every
morning and then have to sit there and
and deal with this anger that I had and
the way and the way that go ahead and
talk about what because you had a longer
term solution I think to me I parse this
out and I really like both ingredients
here these perspectives that I want to
talk about here there are four different
perspectives that I presented to you
they are helpful in the short term
correct to help you like like okay
realize it's not as bad as I'm as I'm
playing up online right but then there's
also a longer term solution that you
talked about with your therapist and we
can talk through that as well sure let's
get to the short term so because I think
what's important it's like how do we
change our state right now and then well
then we let's talk about how do we
change it longer term how do we change a
long term perspective yes and so the
short term perspective for me it was
something as simple and we talked about
this on a podcast I was having a crappy
morning a few podcasts ago like the
morning just wasn't going well and and I
didn't sleep well and then like there
was all these I wanted to get to the
office earlier to prepare more and it
just didn't happen
but then I almost stepped in this huge
pile of dog [ __ ] and that's why I'm
laughing ladies and gentlemen is because
I'm looking down at the show Josh does a
really nice job preparing these notes
before every podcast and the show
starter the first note on there is dog
[ __ ] so so say you almost stepped in dog
[ __ ] right and and I realized that day
like okay it's a shitty morning but it
could be literally shittier because I
could have stepped in darker and then
last week I'm walking in down my hallway
and no one
my apartment on my floor has a dog that
I'm aware of but there is his dog [ __ ]
all over the hallway Wow and like these
huge it looks like you know some Mastiff
was there or something but the funny
thing is I saw this really old woman
maybe in her like mid 80s getting on the
elevator as I was getting off and she
had this like dog that was you know it
wasn't a very big dog it had to be this
dog she just didn't notice that he was
just crap crapping all over the hallway
and and it's like that's terrible but it
could have been worse I'd always I could
you know I could have fallen in and I
could be on my shoe or whatever and
that's that's the sort of funny
perspective change it's realizing like
no matter how bad something is it could
be worse you could have stepped in
[ __ ] but then there are other like
serious perspective perspective shifts
you know we're talking about there's a
pastor who I follow on social media his
name is Judas Smith who he runs a church
in Seattle and I really like some of the
the the stories that he tells and he
talks about these these perspectives
that we have and how we set ourselves up
for disappointment he was giving this
story about a friend of his Michael
Porter Jr who who was drafted in in the
most recent NBA Draft and now a year ago
or maybe even six months before the
draft
he was projected to be number one in the
draft like just really solid basketball
player and they're fairly Cerner he's
gonna go number one if he didn't go to
number one he was deaf they're gonna be
in the top two or three but pretty sure
he's gonna be number one but as the
draft comes around they people find out
he has a slight back injury and so he
starts to become more questionable even
though he's one of the best players
going into the draft that year and and
so the draft night comes around and Jude
is all happy because he's like oh we're
gonna get drafted the night even though
you know he's a 40 year old guy in
Seattle who doesn't play basketball but
he's like I might you know it's like if
you were going to be an NBA draft where
I was gonna be an NBA draft all of a
sudden we'd be really excited for each
other right and and you would feel like
you were being drafted into the NBA if I
was yes I still have hopes I'm still
holding out me too man I'm rooting for
waiting for the Utah Jazz to call any
day now anyway so the draft night comes
around and first pick he doesn't get
drafted second third pick doesn't get
drafted and they're like okay what's
going on here make it down the top seven
the top seven like the really good
players doesn't get drafted in the top
seven make it to eight nine ten
now the lottery only has fourteen
players and then beyond that it's just a
second sequential thing but so they make
it to number 12 doesn't get your Aven
umber 13 doesn't get drafted and then
for the 14th pick the Denver Nuggets
picked Michael Porter Jr and and all of
a sudden it's like oh wow
this guy was supposed to be number one
yeah this high everyone had this
expectation for him everyone who knew
him was like you're gonna be the top
draft pick of of of the year
expectations yeah I'll tell you what hey
pay your crippling right set us up and
so they're interviewing him afterward
and it's it's almost like this
backhanded compliment it's like oh you
got drafted but isn't it disappointing
that you didn't make it to number one
and he just looked at the person
interview and he was like oh no like I I
don't deserve anything mm-hmm
I I think it's just a blessing that I
get to be here I get to play in the NBA
next year how awesome is that
yeah and shifting that around like wow
the standard here is I get to play in
the NBA by the way I'm a first-round
draft pick how awesome is that I love
that dude he doesn't deserve anything
it's like I feel like a lot of a lot of
my woes came from these these
expectations I had these things that I
felt I deserved worse felt that I was
entitled to yeah and just that's a
beautiful example of how the less we
feel were entitled to the lower
expectations are but the higher the
standards yes we can take this
experience that yeah everyone else is
looking at all poor you were so sorry
for you and we don't have to necessarily
feel that way and
standard is I'm gonna play basketball to
the best of my ability yeah regardless
of what the the outcome is with yeah
what draft pick I am right because
here's the thing the the Rookie of the
Year one of the rookies a year last year
played for the Utah Jazz Donovan
Mitchell and he was drafted 27th Wow and
and now everyone's like man he should
have been 1st or 2nd right and and all
you have to do is prove yourself with
the high standards yeah
because otherwise you say you get drop
how many people have been drafted number
two or number three or even number one
and they amounted to nothing every year
don't get me started on the Bengals
right and I think that's the point is I
do have high expectations for these
people but if they don't have the
standards it doesn't work out then
what's it worth anyway and so I think
sometimes Ryan we we talk about what you
deserve what you're entitled to I think
with your parent a situation with your
situation with your dad maybe there were
times where you felt you see other
people with great parents yeah I think
about my partner Rebecca and she like
grew up on this idyllic childhood with
two parents who stayed Mary they're
still married right now yeah lived on a
farm middle-class and lay you know I
should be I should have that too we're
entitled to that right that's what I
should have no you shouldn't have
anything yeah I'm lucky enough to be
here yeah
exactly man I mean if we're entitled to
anything so I asked this question to
people all the time because it is an
interesting question I don't know the
answer to it but I do think that we
probably are born with some entitlements
and I've heard people say when I asked
him the question like what do you think
we're entitled to people will say oh you
know what clean water or maybe clean air
which we you have to fight for that
stuff
I mean we hardly get that but but the
best answer I got was this dude in
Ireland back when Mariah and I were
there and I think I was like September
of 2015 maybe so long ago um but I asked
them we're sitting at the pub and I'm
like you know I got a question I like to
ask people when you seem like you'd have
a good answer to this what do you feel
like we are born entitled to wit when we
are born on this earth what are we
entitled to and he looked at me he was
like peace mmm to be left alone and I
was like dude that is good man like that
is that is absolutely good but but but
to your point though of entitlement
slake there's an
thing that we are born into this world
that says you have to have this you need
to have that you are entitled to have
this and and yes that goes with with
having awesome parents like I really
wish I had awesome parents like Mariah
has or like Bex has I wish that we had
these awesome flourishing relationships
and they've gotten better over the years
sure um but like with my mom like I am
connecting with her in a way that I
never thought that we would actually be
able to connect with my dad it's it's
kind of going the opposite way but my
point is is that I can work towards
having good parents and I can put that
on me and do as much work as I can and
support them as much as I can and be a
good son as much as I can but just
because I show them respect just because
I go out of my way to appreciate accept
them to support them doesn't necessarily
mean that I'm entitled to get it back
now I get to choose how how much energy
and how much of my resources I put into
those relationships right but just
because I do X Y & Z yes there's a
possibility that a B and C will happen
but nothing nothing in this world and
titles a B and C to happen yeah and even
the things you talked about with I mean
to me I would love to think that it's a
right that we have clean air clean water
and peace like to me those seem like
fundamental but right there are plenty
of cavemen who didn't have access to
clean water or the air was messed up cuz
a meat-eor hit or whatever yeah they
were even even back then they weren't
entitled to it and peace by the way
human existence has been violent for all
of human history until very recently
yeah we're if you go to who was it was I
think it's Steven Pinker and
enlightenment now is that the book yeah
so in there he writes about how if you
go to South Side Chicago and it's
extremely violent violent you go to
over-the-rhine in Cincinnati in the late
90s second most violent neighborhood in
the country you go to West Dayton today
or you go to any any any neighborhood in
North America that is a developed we're
a very developed relatively peaceful
nation but there are neighborhoods that
are extremely violent it's over 600
people were were killed in South Side
Chicago last year you know if you go out
throughout human history that was
actually
gnorm right Southside Chicago is the
norm throughout human history the
anomaly is us right now like we're here
we're here in Los a safe part of Los
Angeles yeah it's funny to think man
this is the safest time in human history
right like it is the most peaceful time
there there is one war going on right
now in the Western Hemisphere right it's
like the drug war with late I don't I
don't know where somewhere in South
America that's going on but besides that
I mean it is this is one of the most
peaceful times in in history for sure
and so the things we think of as an as
anomalies now it's actually the opposite
yeah we don't we're not even entitled to
peace even though we we feel like we
should be right yeah again that helped
user perspective oh yeah yeah I want to
differentiate when I say peace I don't
mean like peace on earth I do mean being
left alone as far as that goes but
you're right like even even that point
that maybe some people go and you know
going to move into a cabin on the side
of a mountain in the middle of nowhere
Montana then they are left alone but by
and large you're right man like that is
not something that every single person
on this earth can can expect and even
they will not be left alone yeah try not
to pay your taxes and really in that in
that cabinet absolutely you will be
forced into a violently into a jealous
jail cell yeah and so even that we're
not and so it just really shifts our
perspective on on entitlements
right now the next thing that I saw was
on Joe Rogan's podcast you and I were
talking about a guy named Michael Scott
Moore he wrote a book about for almost
three years I think was two years and
eight months he was captured by Somali
pirates it's crazy
2014 I think is when this happened and
so and he was certain he was going to
die basically because they wanted 20
million dollars in order to return him
and he's a journalist you know it's like
I don't make any money like didn't you
say he laughed when they said twenty
million dollars you know I call your
close relative tell them you want 20
million dollars and he was like yeah and
I mean the first thing I did was they
broke his hand they hit him in the face
with a with a shotgun but or ak-47
butter went and and basically fed him
crap and
like he developed all kinds of like
autoimmune issues and I mean dying
essentially yeah and then eventually he
he's able to get out through a whole
negotiation process and and now that
he's like I mean he went through in
surprise still does go through traumatic
PTSD yeah and has recovered mostly but
even like sleeping at night is difficult
for him but he's like I realize now like
the things that used to make me upset
like getting stuck in traffic right it
could be worse you could be kidnapped by
Somali pirates yeah I like this is
anyway hands broken yeah this is great
compared to yeah and every night they
chained him to a bed good God and so
like it's hard for him to sleep because
like he gets anxiety around like if it's
nighttime that means that's the time
where I'm getting chained to a bed yeah
and I may or may not get beaten tonight
Wow and so that perspective shift just
thinking about that it was like oh yeah
and then the the last story that you and
I talked about and this was really
unfortunate J Alston from our
documentary minimalism tiny house guy
last week was killed by Isis it sounds
so weird later yeah I mean we only got
to see him a couple times and I I mean
I've communicated with him via email and
text and I always thought like I you
know hang out whenever we go to DC or if
he was in DC at the same time so he and
his his wife or partner they decided
we're gonna travel the world we're gonna
biker right there really passion about
biking and they had done long bike trips
before and then went to go around the
world on a bike trip right and so they
decided hey now's the time they quit
their jobs he he had someone take care
of his tiny house for him the same tiny
house it's in the documentary and
they've been blogging about their
experiences sharing on Instagram taking
photos and day 365 there in the country
it's not Turkmenistan it's country right
next to it right above Afghanistan
starts with the tea I forget the name
sorry yeah yeah it's it's one of the
ministers insert the word here Sean yeah
no thanks no Sean Sean I'm Jordan on the
on the
we'll put the name of the country on
right yeah and right here and anyway he
was he and his his girl for wife were
biking with five other people's a group
of seven of them biking for country
she's absolutely gorgeous so looking at
the pictures but it's also really
difficult their journey was difficult
you know it's cold sometimes at hot and
their their backpacking and they're on
their bikes and they get flat tires yeah
people accidentally run them off the
road sometimes because there's different
customs and different countries
anyway they're with us this pact of
seven people on their bicycles and all
of a sudden a van just swerves and hits
all seven of them all throw they get out
of the van and just start stabbing them
to death don't believe it what's so
tragic man and my heart goes out to all
of his family and friends I mean that's
such a tragic thing yeah and I was I was
talking to someone someone from the New
York Times reached out to me and I'm
just asking me about him and I was
talking to her on on the phone about it
and I was I was both grateful like that
we had the opportunity to to know him
but I was also grateful at the
opportunity like to live this this dream
this this passion of his it's so
unfortunate that it led to what it led
to
but he lived the last year of his life
doing what they wanted to do and it
wasn't easy no it was it was difficult
but it was simple and they chose to
leave behind the life that was not
fulfilling and lived that last year and
it reminded me of our friend stand and
we've actually done an episode about
about stand me you and in podcast Sean
we all worked with back in the corporate
world one of one of our closest friends
yeah and he died at 30 36 or 37 he was I
think 36 yeah yeah mid thirties yeah
yeah we and he had a heart attack
tragically young yeah and and died and
but he like he lived a life that a lot
of people wouldn't have lived at all and
like you in that attenuated life there
was real life it was real living yeah
and so the essay and we'll put a link to
the essay and in the show notes it's
called live like Stan
and it it is it was sort of a a tribute
to his life but realizing like wow like
J or like Stan like we can die any any
day yeah any moment yeah
you